russell wilson's four-team wish list as
provided by his agent mark rogers on the
record cowboys bears
raiders
and saints the teams to which russell
wilson would accept a trade
that makes it interesting if drew brees
is thinking about
playing again and drew brees may be
upset to say the least with the idea
that russell wilson is sniffing around a
job that isn't open yet right and then
chris
it gets complicated by this that emerged
on saturday
new orleans mayor latoya cantrell making
an unabashed pitch for russell wilson to
come to new orleans here it is
i've heard the rumors now
and i want to make sure that you
understand that the city of new orleans
is a place for you
and your beautiful family i'm latoya
cantrell mayor of the city of new
orleans and i know
mr wilson that you will be a great
addition to the new orleans saints and
more importantly i can see us in that
number winning that super bowl
championship once again and what else i
can see the misses sierra wilson herself
on that main stage during the historical
essence festival just wanted to stop
then to let you know that we
not only admire you
we we want you love you man love sierra
love your beautiful family the culture
of the city of new orleans awaits
you
drew brees hasn't even retired yet i
know he is synonymous with new orleans
are you kidding me and now uh seattle
mayor jenny durkin chimes in
uh i love you mayor but keep your eyes
off wilson his home in seattle yeah and
none of none of this matters none of
this matters because russell's already
sold on new orleans it's one of the four
teams he's identified we'll talk about
those four teams more in a minute but
th this whole russell wilson interested
in the saints brees hasn't retired it's
becoming shakespearean
well i i would like to like and maybe
somebody from new orleans can can
comment to us during the show
but
i i don't know what the news cycle is
down there but maybe they're in the same
boat we i don't think it's a shot at
drew brees
i think
everybody expected it to be it for drew
brees and i'm sure they felt like he's
gonna retire down there too i don't know
what the local media has has been saying
about you know drew brees at the end of
the season and those type of things but
i'm sure they've been led to believe
that this was kind of it as well so uh
it i mean it's it's weird that the
mayor's getting involved in all that
and hey
russell wilson would of course be
awesome in that offense anybody's gonna
be awesome in that offense with sean
payton let alone you know russell wilson
at this point of his career you know the
problem with that is
you know
what are the what are the seahawks going
to get back you know that that's that's
going to be the interesting thing
they're going to try to taste some hill
and jason james winston up there i don't
i don't know well i can't trade james
winston because he's a free agent
yeah before we yeah vega trade some hill
plus draft picks plus whoever i'll i'll
tell you what i think about that in a
minute let me just say this yeah when
you think about how widespread this
belief is that drew brees is retiring
you know the toothpaste is completely
out of the tube and he just kind of
stood there and watched it spray like at
some point you've got to say
i i right no i i may come back i don't
know where all this is coming from folks
but i may come back he has not behaved
like a guy until the past couple of
weeks
that that
is thinking about playing football so
one of the reasons we're at this point
where everyone assumes he's done is
everyone has articulated that assumption
and he said nothing
nothing to push back against it until
very recently he still hasn't said
anything yeah right it's just the
silence coupled with the
workout video has people wondering
what really is going on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports